Pastiche recipe also
contains 60 different
herbs and spices, each
of which is separately
distilled into alcohol.
One of these herbs is
Artemisia vulgaris,
commonly known as
mugwort.
A worker loads mugwort
leaves into a tank filled
with a mixture of water
and alcohol.
As the leaves soak, the
alcohol acts as a
solvent, extracting the
aromatic molecules.
This process is called
maceration.
After a few days,
workers drain the
alcoholic liquid now
infused with aromatic
molecules. It's so
alcoholic that it emits
volatile fumes.
So workers wear an alarm
that goes off when the
surrounding air reaches
an explosive level.